be against us
but does every problem have to be solved
by the loudest voices or the biggest
armies
tonight world sporting authorities are
in turmoil
football and boxing have thrown russian
athletes out of international
competition
now the iconic wimbledon tournament has
gone a step further the players past and
present are furious
martina navratilova herself a refugee
from russian domination protests that
players shouldn't be held responsible
for their government's actions
and punished for being born in the wrong
place
inevitably the french have taken a
different stance to the brits allowing
russians like world number two daniel
medvedev and arena sabalenka to compete
as long as they don't wave the russian
flag
many say that sport shouldn't be put at
the service of politics
but the supporters of the band argue
that's exactly what always happens
anyway and that the famously sportsman
russian president would be hurt more by
a wimbledon ban than any number of un
resolutions and they point out that
sporting bands were crucial to the
defeat of apartheid
so our choice should the russians be
banned from wimbledon or is there a
better way to stop putin
in the next 60 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
and coming up later on the show we'll
hear from ukraine's top female tennis
player elena fidelina who has been as
high as third in the world rankings and
what she thinks should happen
but with me tonight in studio dr mike
dignan director of the observatory for
human rights and events at the
university of surrey and editor-in-chief
of event management the journal for the
study of events and festivals and dr
rachel pistol historian and research
fellow at king's college london
let's begin
if we can by preparing the ground find
out a bit more about our two guests and
what they
believe uh if i can start uh with you
mike
um
what is the case for the ban imposed by
the england all england club
so the idea with with the ban is that
that by exerting some form of economic
and social pressure um on
russia on putin's regime then the idea
is that piece by piece
if every event does these kinds of
specific actions then then we can exert
enough pressure uh to um to reduce the
likelihood that the putin will continue
uh in that in that regime
now um i i know you'll as we have
discussed it you'll say that this is
nuance and so on but you've you've
definitely taken a position um why does
this matter at all to you personally
i think it's about understanding the
broader uh uses of events really and
we've spent a decade working with um
events festivals of all shapes and sizes
um to look at how they can do social
good
and uh there's a lot of different ways
in which they could be leveraged um to
exert pressure on
regimes whereby um there is human rights
abuses violations
and events and festivals are a great
platform for doing that as we've seen
with various other major events in the
past
but they also serve as a bat signal to
say when social change is needed and i
think that it's really on the event
owners and organizers to understand the
power and potential of their event for
shaping public discourse um
they are important tools for doing that
uh rachel um
why do you oppose this ban
well i come at this very much from a
perspective of being a historian who's
looked at
what happens in terms of refugee
refugees immigration xenophobia
and what happens to foreigners
living in in other countries uh during
times of war
and so really whilst i i completely
appreciate where mike's coming from um
i'm i'm looking at how this affects
individuals who actually might have
taken a stance against uh against russia
in this instance um or against whatever
the warring nation is and actually how
this affects them and and saying whilst
i complete i mean whilst i completely
support the idea of of banning anything
that relates to sort of team sports or
anything that really
is is key in terms of uh boosting
russia's
international image um i take a very
different stance when it comes to what
happens with individuals
unless they're actively using their
position
to actually promote the war
um how
much effect is this really going to
happen in trying to stop putin
why does it matter to you i mean this is
basically some people banging balls
across a net um
is it really that important to you
personally it all comes down to
discrimination um and and and how you're
discriminating uh against people and if
you look at the history in the in the
20th and the 21st century and how
people have been dehumanized by by
having labels applied to them whether
that be their nationality whether it be
the color of their skin whether it be
their religion um i think it's just we
have to be very careful it's very fine
line
that you walk down before this turns
into something much more sinister
okay well
we've already uh established one piece
of common ground i think let me check
this with with you that this is actually
just a lot more important than
what a few
talented millionaires who are good with
a racket do
for you mike it's actually about
how we affect social or political in
this case geopolitical change for you is
how we resist um
discrimination of how we identify and
how we resist discrimination is that
the first point that we we agree this is
something much more important than just
a game of tennis yes and it's and it's
really difficult to understand which
side to fall on it depends if you
empathize with the individual um and
it's really hard to not be compassionate
about the individual plight but
the point in which maybe we depart or
differ is that i think that there is a
broader problem there's a broader
emergency and emergencies require
emergency responses and um and emergency
responses are uncomfortable
and and it's very difficult to know
really what what will what will what is
the right responses particularly when
we're in the fog of war
literally right now so yeah i mean i i
think it it's
uh i mean even as andy murray said he
said there's not necessarily a right
decision because of course there are
arguments on both sides so it's how how
you apply this and actually what makes
this situation so different from say
other humanitarian crises that perhaps
aren't being supported in in similar
ways that i mean i think that's um
that's one issue um as it's i mean even
down into the details such as the the
fact that at the moment it's only the
players who are banned so if you're a
russian or a belarusian physiotherapist
or um
physiotherapist or umpire or somebody
like that then you can actually
technically still possibly attend
okay well
let's come down into the detail and if i
may say so you're both being uh
stupendously reasonable uh
thus far but let's get down into the
detail and see if this
atmosphere of um love and harmony
survives let's let's
first talk to you about your
uh
case uh mike
the players are going to be banned
aren't on this occasion representing
their nations why punish them it's got
nothing to do with them
it hasn't got anything to do with them
but i think it for me it it confuses two
things i think the first thing is that
it's not about the individuals at all at
all and that's why i have um i have a
challenge thinking about that this is a
xenophobic particular issue i think that
because the issue is much more broader
i think that we have to transcend in
this case national identity
and and think well what is the thing
that we should be doing to alleviate the
wider problem so i don't think it is an
issue with the individual uh for example
i saw rachel's article about um cats uh
being um
been taken away from a feline
competition which i think is a really
important point and if it was not this
case if it wasn't its war on european
soil um then i would agree
but i think that
getting rid of cats and feline
competitions is is is an important issue
but i think that there are bigger fish
to fry in this sense and i think that we
need there's some people unfortunately
that have to be part of the the the
collateral damage of this though we
don't want anyone to be before we go
further but you might like to explain to
uh uh
viewers uh rachel the entire cat
question because
look
there's some confusion here between cats
and and fish and all that so just
explain just yeah i mean i think it's
really yeah
it's interesting that you picked up on
that one um
piece of the article um but yes i mean
the entire article looks at actually how
how russophobic events had had actually
been taking place in the west in in
britain and in america where actually
people who had russian
names all russian sounding names were
being targeted because people felt that
they wanted to do something in order to
help the um
ukrainian
war effort and uh it's it's this idea
that you really need to do some action
make some action so you ban cats from
capcom beyond russian breeds from cat
competitions and you you ban russian
music from from um concerts but what i
argue is that actually you know how much
is that really helping ukrainians is
that more of a tokenistic effort to make
you feel better rather than actually
doing something positive that that might
help the victims of it is not a problem
mike that actually you might say this is
not really about individuals but it's
about
their national identity but in truth the
action that takes place is against and
about individuals rather than
uh nation to nation
it is and and it's unfortunate that
individuals are caught up in this
maelstrom uh that's where we definitely
agree um the the question is you know
and in that article there are some
really deep points which is that you
know there are people that have been
xenophobic towards russian people um
that people have been looting uh russian
firms
and without a doubt people get caught in
that and and rachel mentions that that's
people who have you know perhaps full of
some form of hatred will take it out but
they will take it out on them and
various other people who they don't like
in various other cases and and i think
that that is them doing something but
they do not represent
yeah but but let's let's just uh
dwell with this question about whether
you can separate the individual from
from their national identity let's say
take for example
um someone who in this country had voted
to remain
in 2016
um
the vote went the other way
that doesn't mean that they can now when
they're on a pla they're in an italian
or a french airport and they're entering
that space they can say oh look don't
blame me uh uh i want to go in the eu
queue because that's where i wanted to
stay
if you are british
that's your decision
it's not you can't claim it's got
nothing to do with me unless of course
you renounce your nationality
yeah it's it's again it's it's
unfortunate that individuals get caught
up uh in in in the maelstrom of it all
um
people are individual they are russian
nationals
obviously but fundamentally my view and
my point of this is that we have to
transcend the individual
to think on a more collective and bigger
level and unfortunately there has to be
in these cases some sort of casualty to
put more pressure because i think that
although individually it looks fairly
significant just banning a player or two
collectively piece by piece and
cumulatively it it adds weight
on weight on weight and weight and i
think that we have to do it i think we
need to just constantly see that bigger
picture um although clearly lots of
things are xenophobic
well i mean and that's just because
civilians are always the collateral
damage uh and and you're always uh tired
with the brush of of whatever is going
on with your government um
regardless of whether you support it as
you mentioned with with brexit it's
exactly the same i mean at the outbreak
of war you had the mp uh for north vanet
in kent roger gale saying we should send
all russians home even though there'd be
some good and honest people who would
naturally get caught up in the
collateral damage and and yeah on the
flip side of that you have to think that
actually many of the people who live in
the west who are russians live here for
a reason and that is because they don't
support their government and or their
their they have dissented in some way
that makes it unsafe for them to return
to their home country indeed some of
these tennis players russian tennis
players specifically do not live in
russia i mean
they may live in monaco for tax reasons
but they don't live in russia
no no they don't they don't and i think
that
it's for me it's just going back to the
point about the xenophobia you know i i
went on to the cambridge english
dictionary and had a look at just what
the definition was and it was an extreme
dislike or fear of foreigners their
customs their religions and you know
going back to the central question of
whether wimbledon should ban they aren't
banning on xenophobic grounds
fundamentally they're they're banning
based on a much broader political and
economic pressure grounds and i think
that it's really important to come back
to that point come on can i just ask you
one i guess one last
practical question
will peace in care i mean actually is
there a danger that banning uh russian
players might actually play into his
narrative that he now goes on telly in
uh moscow and says to russians you see i
told you they hate us i told you the
west really just wants to persecute us
and now our you know our brilliant
russian players are being excluded not
for anything they've done but because
people do not like russians exactly
uh rachel's point i agree i agree it
will play there's obviously a polar
opinion there's that there's the view in
the media that that in russia putin has
a lot of support but yet when you look
on the ground you see a lot of political
resentment and and dissent so you know
depending on your position depending on
your group you're going to see
um you're going to see um it in
completely different ways it's going to
play into the hands of ones and then not
play into the hands of the others so you
know how you how are you going to
resolve that that that challenge can use
this however however it's played out he
will be able to use it for some sort of
political capital anyway um but i think
it's also really important to to
remember that we are looking at a
difference between i mean obviously
you've already had all of your you know
russian and belarusian um team sports
they've already been banned from
competing and everything and we're not
talking about the davis cup here where
people are representing their country
we're talking about individuals who
actually um i mean on the rest of the
tennis circuit they're actually able to
not have their flag or nationality
put up so essentially playing as
neutrals and and i think
it's a very different situation when
you've got people who are actively using
their position and fame to support pete
and so if you take all the cases in the
olympics which of course you'll be very
familiar with and that's very different
but i'm sure you're going to come to
that
yeah we will well look i think there's
quite a lot of agreement here between
two of you that we need to be reasonable
but interestingly you're both being
incredibly reasonable about the fact
that you won't agree about what to do um
i'll be testing the ground a bit further
with
rachel's view in a moment stay with us
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined by dr mike dignan director of the
observatory for human rights and events
at the university of surrey and dr
rachel pistol historian and research
fellow at king's college london we're
talking about whether russian players
should be banned from wimbledon
um
rachel
it cannot be right to force ukrainian uh
players to share a court with people
who haven't condemned the invasion of
their country surely
well that is that is the real issue
isn't it in terms of whether in the draw
you get russians and
and ukrainians drawn against each other
particularly if they they haven't i mean
if you look at
many of the big name
um players who are being banned they
have actually
said that they want to promote peace
they they're not interested in war um
yeah but that's not the same thing as
saying mr putin get your tanks out of
donette that uh the score and i think we
have to remember that that russia is not
a democracy there are very half
penalties against anybody who expresses
dissent so so in terms of these
individuals we have to think about what
sorts of reprisals might be made on
their families as well which is is
the most likely explanation of what's
holding them back from actually publicly
saying if you if you look at the recent
law putin put in that's jailing people
for up to 15 years for spreading what is
called false information about the war
which is essentially telling anybody
what is actually happening um the the
penalties are high so
there is always that threats of coercion
as well which is possibly
um
hindering people plus the idea of i mean
you've got your nationality because of
where you were born you obviously had no
say in where you were were born and to
renounce your nationality is actually a
very big thing and you run the risk of
becoming stateless i mean with tennis
players very unlikely i'm sure you know
you'll be able to um
actually uh seek asylum somewhere else
uh but it's it's actually a very
big process
um
so this this will be holding a lot of
them back from making bolder statements
isn't that right mike actually the the
the
wimbledon band to be precise is that
players
are not allowed to play unless
they make a statement repudiating
the invasion but as rachel just pointed
out
that's not just a few words on paper
issued by your par agency that is
putting
your mum
in some serious danger
yeah it's substantive isn't it is it
incredibly substantive and i think that
i think that you know put ourselves in
the position
of the of the players would we do it um
for what nadal says are points on a
tournament ranking i don't i think when
pitted against each other i don't think
i would um so i suspect that we have to
be very very careful um
about what we
think
tennis players should do sports people
should do should sign should give away
their nationality should put their
family in harm um i think it's a case of
what do we prioritize when the chips are
down
what do we prioritize
yeah
but
there is a real world thing here though
rachel isn't there we don't know that
these families will be put at harm and
to be honest um
if anybody can protect their families
it's going to be
a multi-millionaire tennis player who
lives in monaco or switzerland and
basically spend very little time in
russia and who could frankly if he or
she wanted get them out
but you need to be able to get them out
and at the moment that is not a
straightforward issue is it i mean even
if we think about the olympics and when
you look at the um
belarusian
athletes who defected uh
then actually her husband had to then
drive across to poland the borders are
not open now so so you don't have that
ability to just say actually i'm going
to make this statement you need to get
out of the country now it's not possible
but okay well let's let's talk about the
the point that mike made
for the sporting authorities there has
to be a decision made they can't simply
say well nothing to do with us otherwise
isn't there a danger that wimbledon or
whoever else looks like they're simply
complicit
in uh
saying we don't like the invasion but
not doing anything about it which of
course is what
the the authorities run the french open
who said we're not going to do this ban
thing
that's what to some people they look
like they look like
they're ready to talk but actually in
the end they don't mind throwing the
ukrainians to the dogs
the itf have been very clear uh in in
this
tennis federation yes
and they've said that actually
so long as people are competing as
individuals and they're not supporting
um
the war and they are not representing
their country then they see no reason
why they cannot compete as individuals
but in truth they're not competing as
individuals they will be as we've seen
before mr putin anytime anybody russian
wins anything anywhere whether judo or
tiddlywinks or something um he's on uh
russian television um proclaiming that
that uh russia is mighty in world
beating but this isn't actually the
first time that
individuals have been treated
differently from their country so for
example during apartheid in south africa
there were sanctions against the south
african teams they couldn't compete in
the davis cup etc etc but their
individual players could actually
compete
and you even had arthur ashe who is the
uh
he was a black american um
tennis champion who wasn't able to
compete in south africa but he was very
much for putting sanctions on the
country and stopping them from from
doing things but when it came to the
individual players he was very much
against uh people doing takenistic acts
like forfeiting a match against an
individual south african player
because he he fought for the rights of
the individual
mike
interesting yeah i think i think that
i think on your point about soft power
you know the idea that events are used
for political and economic gain as well
as pressure i thought you know i thought
that it was quite interesting in an
article that i wrote that that it's
quite interesting and ironic that these
events that have served such important
political economic platforms for putin
to discuss social and economic policy
and put themselves on the ground stage
have have turned their back against them
and it just shows how powerful they are
um really against against regimes that
that are deemed
you talked about the um the
isolation of south africa
and it is true
that um
some south african athletes and sports
people were able to compete elsewhere
but in truth the south africans
did say
that the sporting ban
and some of which did apply to
individuals in some sport
was one of the most powerful weapons
in um persuading them or compelling them
actually to abandon apartheid
surely a complete ban on russian
participation in international sport
including the individuals
is part of bringing the ukrainian
people's suffering to an end faster
and this is where as i was saying
these sanctions against the teams
definitely do work against the
individuals it it's it's much less
effective but the the teams
that's really very important
less effective because it for russians
uh the the sort of emotional and
political impact of
uh medvedev being banned or some um one
of their boxers let's say being banned
is
as important as uh for them as their
football team being banned surely well i
think you've seen
actually some of the power of the
banning of the individual but these have
been cases where individuals have
actually worn the zed
symbol that is trying to support
russian victory and you see this across
athletics you see this across swimming
and actually some very severe bands have
been implemented um demonstrating that
if you do try and use your
your position to actually promote
putin's position then then you are going
to suffer in terms of the sports worlds
i mean a nine-month ban
on swimming most recently um and and
also um you've also had sanctions on
people who attended uh a putin rally uh
that was supporting uh russian
achievements in in the olympics so so i
think that you are seeing that and i
think where where individuals are saying
that actually we don't we don't support
the war we want peace
that's a very different
scenario to people who are actively
trying to promote russia's course
all right all right well we've heard
from both our guests and we've tested
their positions
a little bit we've roasted both of you
lightly um but let's
begin the search for some common ground
and we'll start
by hearing from a ukrainian tennis star
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined by dr mike dignan director of the
observatory for human rights and events
at the university of surrey and dr
rachel pistol historian and research
fellow at king's college london
we're talking about whether it's right
that russian players should be banned
from wimbledon and we found out some of
what both of our guests think and why
now
if we can
we'd like to find some common ground or
at least a common understanding
but before we do that let's hear from
someone with a very personal stake in
this debate who has her own views on
what should happen
here's the ukrainian tennis player elena
svitolina winner of 16 women's tennis
association tour titles and the former
world number three
she'll be playing at wimbledon this
summer
the best way would be not to bend
completely but
make
them speak about
the war in ukraine to ask them if they
support the invasion in ukraine if they
support their government and if they can
answer those questions if they
say that they don't support it they
don't support putin they don't support
lukashenko then they would be allowed to
to participate and
then we would
see that they they didn't choose
this government that they don't support
what's going on they don't support the
war this would be very clear and if it
could be public
this would make
them um
just be a human
because right now we don't know their
opinion
we see that the russian
army has invaded ukraine and this is
a horrible thing what is happening to
ukrainian people and
what is really really happening uh
true to ukraine how many cities are
destroying
and uh yeah we just won from
from the tennis players to to hear they
their statement regarding regarding this
whatever the
actual detail and the facts of what's
happening in the ground um to some
extent mike uh
elena's virgolina
uh i guess lined up with what rachel
says that if the individual makes their
position clear
they shouldn't and it's and it's anti
the invasion they shouldn't be punished
i i and i think i agree you know you've
got
individual freedom of choice you know
people have been given an option to
choose whether they want one side or the
other if they sign
the document if they if they come out
against the ukraine war then they can
play if not then they're not i think
that there's something kind of broader
which is that there is a way in which
wimbledon could have done this um in a
in a slightly different way perhaps like
the olympics has done it which is
getting them to kind of represent
um themselves
not under
russia they they compete under the flag
of the uh not of the russian federation
but the russian olympic committee
absolutely yeah and and that at least
separates them uh enough and i think
that there is that we haven't
scrutinized enough what wimbledon as
event organizers should have done
differently and i think that again
that's that goes back to my point about
the fog of war people will inevitably be
doing things differently and i think
that we need to learn from like this and
think about what our international and
event collective response will be
you know that's right rachel that there
is that there might be a way through
here through this which is not about
specific the issue of principle but the
manner in which
the principles are applied or have been
applied yes i mean i do think that it's
about the manner that the principles are
applied and so as you're saying it's
about having having that this diff that
distance and and i think that that is um
really important plus if you're going to
do a ban
you need to either make it a blanket fan
or or not if you're only at the moment
banning players but not other officials
who were who might work at wimbledon
like umpires physiotherapists other
things like that then actually
you know i mean i know they're going for
a high profile fan but but it's the it's
the inconsistencies and and how that
works i mean it's certainly been
suggested that this is more of a this
has been more pushed onto the lawn
tennis association by by the government
because they were saying we can't
guarantee that visas will be provided
for these people because of obviously
our stance on the on the war against
ukraine so
um you have to
think about how how much have they
really thought about the practicalities
of how this would work more than is this
just a political decision that's been
forced onto a sporting body
yeah but
let's just step back here a moment here
and
you know i'm sure we could find a sort
of softly softly way through but let's
remember who we're dealing with here
we're dealing with vladimir putin who um
let's leave aside what he did in
chechnya
but for example vo invaded crimea in
2014 everybody
was on
was unhappy everybody shouted and so on
and then they gave him the world cup to
organize
i mean
surely there is a point at which we have
to say
as i think mike was saying earlier on
whatever the
problems for individuals at the edges
we have to take a very hard position if
we're going to stop this kind of thing
coming from moscow again and again and
again
well yes and that's why mike saying that
you have to remove uh the sporting
events you know they shouldn't be given
to russia they shouldn't be in any way
supporting russia and this is true but
this is what what uh the law tennis
association are doing is very different
to what the whole of the rest of the the
um the tennis fed international tennis
federation are doing so so it's it's
they're they they have taken a
unilateral decision which does not
represent the rest of the sport which
has already cancelled uh russia and
bella uh belarus's membership to the
tennis federation um and and doing
various other sanctions i mean i think
it's quite interesting that martina
navratilova who of course defected to
america from um behind the iron curtain
but when it was has actually spoken out
and said that she doesn't think it's
fair to ban the individuals so long as
they don't support the war then so long
as they talk talk for peace um because
obviously she has has some quite
incredible insights that come from her
experiences of of living in a similarly
oppressive system
yeah but mike okay let me come to you
mike because
i get the sense that you're saying
well maybe we could um be
a little bit softer on anybody who comes
up so what is to stop um somebody from
uh mr putin's
inner circle
ringing up a top tennis player and
saying
you know what we do want you to play in
wimbledon
we don't mind if you go a bit silent on
ukraine we'd prefer it if you didn't uh
name mr putin
uh as a terrible dictator or anything
but if you want to say that you're
unhappy and you'd prefer peace and so on
that's fine
go on win the tournament and then we
will then we'll sort all of that out
afterwards don't worry we'll look we
won't we won't put put your mother on in
the ghoul egg
what is it
sensible
to if you like concede uh from the hard
band that where we started that maybe
we'll be soft on some individuals if
they behave properly because people
behave properly
for you know today's reasons and then
they change their minds next week yeah
yeah yeah i agree i think i think that i
think we always pit things as
contradictions it's really annoying like
it's either you know you support the ban
or you don't support the ban and i think
that there's always that middle ground
that middle ground whereby the common
ground which is um essentially there are
informal mechanisms for example you
listed one of them uh whereby you know
there is a way in which to protect
people but also come out as a citizen
but also as a role model because we
haven't discussed the importance of you
know these players as being role models
for the next generation um to come out
and say things against the war effort
but yet
uh still allow russia to to compete uh
in in that so i think that all those
invisible mechanisms that we don't see
need to go on behind the scenes but
there needs to be assurance on the
individual level that that friends
family aren't going to be aren't going
to be killed just sent to the gulags as
you suggested it's not an either
situation is it it's not a it's not a
we're not talking about saying
that you can't both support ukraine and
also be anti the ban on individual
players in in wimbledon
yeah yeah we we obviously don't have um
anybody representing the russian
federation here to explain um their
position and why
you know they are
in the right here and why they're being
persecuted and so on but we read that um
they think that some of the things that
are being said about what they're doing
are not true and so on but let me just
come back to you rachel and
ask you
if you worry that
this idea that really it we shouldn't
punish the individual
essentially allows people essentially to
kid us we know that
mr putin and many of his associates
have protested
in a sense they've never done anything
wrong but actually the truth is
they
in practice as far as we know may well
support this invasion
how how do we know
unless somebody specifically does
something
uh to put themselves on the side of the
ukrainians that their silence or their
soft words
aren't disguising support for this
invasion
and this is where we have to look at
actions how how are people acting how
are people acting within the circuits as
well i mean we've just heard um from a
ukrainian tennis player and and there
are other
others who are saying this in terms of
let's talk to people find out what's
happening on an individual level rather
than just branding them and tarring them
with the same brush given their
nationality and so you're looking at
actions and and we can see that athletes
have very much many athletes not i'm not
talking about tennis players but outside
of that have been incredibly vocal in
their support for putin so it's it's a
seems that most people
who want to make it known that they they
support putin do not have a problem with
that or and they're quite happy to
accept the um sanctions that come with
that as well all right look this is the
part of the show where uh i i try a
third way a
a trevor uh solution on on both of you
um to see and i i should warn you
normally it's completely rejected but
let me let me try let me try this on you
what if we said that
fine uh russians may play
but uh as long as this
situation in ukraine goes on they may
not win any price money and that prize
money will be donated
to uh
the cause of ukrainian refugees
that is positive you see that's more
than just a takenistic thing of saying
well we might just ban a couple of
famous players if you're actually doing
something practical that is going to
assist ukrainians then i think that that
is a much more positive approach
what do you think mike
without withhold that will hurt with all
the prize money it's uh it's hard to
deny uh giving money to ukraine who that
means would be would be positive
however i think it misses the point i
think that the point is by
you know as
putin rains down rockets on ukraine
and we can't go in there physically
um to to support the effort then we have
to use social
cultural political means outside of the
geographical borders in order to exert
pressure and i so i don't think that
that achieves that
uh although it does achieve money going
into the um the ukrainian uh uh refugee
crisis for example which is important um
but but i don't think i can
association of course the fact that they
banned russians this is not just
wimbledon this is all of the grass
tournaments in the uk and whereas
wimbledon's not going to really suffer
financially from that and the rest of
the british tournaments and potentially
you know so who is really suffering how
much pressure is banning a few
russians
from uh playing in the wimbledon
tournament and not affiliated you know
with russia officially um going to
effect is that going to hurt putin more
than actually
sort of penalizing all grass tennis
competitions this year is but you know
maybe that's a price worth paying yeah
well
since since both of you have now
robbed me of my prospects of becoming
the the mediator in this terrible
situation by rejecting my brilliant
solution can i just ask you one
last thing which i think you may both
agree about
if this wimbledon decision stands
um others are going to copy it aren't
they
they they will do and they already have
done you know we've already discussed
different examples of formula one
eurovision
fifa et cetera they've all kind of come
behind they haven't had the same
policies in terms of how they've done it
or how they've banned and i think that
that's strange because they should be
united as an international sports
grouping of event owners but yeah
they're all going to come into alignment
um and so they should because they it
because what's happening at the
international level is that these events
and festivals and owners are writing
into the operational mandates and
protocols essentially human rights is
fundamental to the delivery of these
things just look at qatar 2022 with the
migrant workers deaths i think that sort
of thing
is is becoming very very prominent yeah
and do you know what i completely agree
with that
okay that's the sort of thing the
television host never wants to hear but
uh that's fine on this occasion um
coming up we've heard from our guests
and they've heard from each other um
high degree of agreement but we will ask
them whether they see any prospect for
common ground on the actual decision
and i'll give my view stay with us
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined once again by dr mike dignan and
dr rachel pistol we've been talking
about whether it's right that russian
players should be banned from wimbledon
well we're coming to the end so i'm
going to give each of you a minute to
tell me what you feel you might have
learned from our conversation
and if anything you've heard has changed
your mind about the other view mike
first
i think that you know it's certainly
something that the region said in terms
of the you know that
the impact on the individual and i think
it's really easy to forget about the
individual impact and that there might
be a more creative solution to this
instead of kind of solving the
contradiction between banning or not
banning and i think that there's it's
really important to recognize that there
is always a space in between of
negotiations so i think that that's
that's a really key thing but i think
that as we've seen there's been a lot of
things that we have agreed on um as
academics as in the spirit of debate um
but you know i would still
ban
because i believe in the um the
political and economic pressure that
that puts on and piece by piece that's
really really important i think
yeah i agree that there are certain we
do have areas of common ground i i
i think the the significance of what
you're saying in terms of how
these bans are enforced and this and the
pressure that they do exert on a country
are really significant i do think that
that action needs to be taken um i still
think that it's really important to
think about some of this sort of
collateral damage and how how that
affects people and how
this can be managed in sort of a more
positive way for
for sort of innocent casualties i'm not
talking about just anyone i'm just
talking about people who who perhaps are
very anti-putin but but wish to still
play their their sports
well both of you have been absolutely
preposterously reasonable in this
discussion um mike you you started with
the idea that
that we have to pay attention to the
individual in the end we're in a
situation where the interests of whole
populations have to take precedence
and you rachel worried about the impact
of decisions which might look like and
actually be discriminating um it's very
interesting here that in a peculiar way
britain which has historically been more
interested in individual freedom uh has
taken a decision
against that where france which has
always been more interested in
exercising role of the state has done
the opposite
i guess that what worries me most is
that we just let things go
and i worry a great deal that's why i
want to say let's take the money away
but i guess in the end of it
i have to say that probably what
bothered me most is the potential for
putin propaganda here
but anyway thank you for a really
stimulating discussion
see you all next week
[Music]
you